[Music]
the real-life incredible last night
Smith jada jada no trace Will Smith is
taking on the haters the 49 year olds
released this video teasing his upcoming
new music and he's slamming tabloid
reports about his marriage to Jada
Pinkett Smith 20 years a swag you'll
just witness stop the divorce rumors and
mind your damn business of course this
isn't the first time Smith has shut down
split speculation in August 2015 he took
to Facebook writing quotes Jada and I
are not getting a divorce
we're not getting a divorce in June of
that year Jada spoke out to ET and also
denied any trouble in their marriage
there's actually good news and bad news
the good news is there's nothing else to
talk about this has been the only story
[Laughter]
let's round up that divorce story again
will and I love each other so much and
and you know our family and our
relationship is so important you would
think that people would be rooting for
you to stay together well not to break
up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]